Save a Horse Ride a ride a bowl yeah
write a bowl is that how
I got Candace Charles is gonna try it
anyway what do you think yeah PBR is in
town of course for the last time this
year or the last time ever in Las Vegas
they're moving to Texas but it's gonna
be a big show T-Mobile Candace all right
let's do it let's ride some Bulls what's
going on
okay you guys sound just as nervous as I
do so you shouldn't but it's the moment
you've all been waiting for I'm finally
gonna hop on this boat but before I do
that of course we gotta talk to the
professionals we got Ross Freeman here
from Arizona he's getting ready for the
championship this weekend tell us a
little bit about what people can expect
yeah so it's the first ever Team Series
Championship uh eight teams going
head-to-head five on five and uh I'm a
part of the Arizona Ridge Rider so come
check it out here and you're not going
to want to miss it okay now Ralston
this when he was 14.
horses takes practice in time they've
been training me a little bit we got LJ
here with us as well he is a former
professional bull rider okay walk me
through this I'm gonna give you the mic
all right so what you're going to do is
just crawl over and put your foot on him
and you're gonna let him know you're
coming down on him
one leg up right one leg up
swing the other leg over your left leg
swing that go ahead and swing that over
there you go
I got you yeah the other watch Candace
the other left now we now he knows your
your real business now
yeah
yeah you're in control okay
there you go all right guys there you go
oh ladies and gentlemen got enough
[Applause]
okay
starting today at seven see I got you
covered still with the details because
I'm awesome and of course you can enjoy
the championship and see Ross and cheer
him on starting Friday at 7 45.
hopefully see you all on Sunday at 1 45
congratulations and good luck thank you
guys so much for joining me this morning
for now I'm Candace Charles I made it I
really will thank you Jesus I'm alive
you know I feel very proud of myself you
should the bull riders run for eight
full seconds that was like eight
milliseconds but it took her like eight
minutes to get on the ball
yeah
you're coming out here next time
fair enough fair enough I got addition I
gotta do it okay all right